what was my goal in making the book it
was the so called publishing event of
the century the drop of Madonna's racy
coffee table book sex and only Ichi has
the inside story behind the book that
left people shook straight from the
material girl herself you mean you
didn't read the text
by 1992 madonna had been delivering
shock-and-awe for nearly a decade so in
the lead up to her fifth studio album
erotica she decided to up the stakes
it's very Madonna s to coincide with the
Records debut Madonna put together a
book of explicit photography featuring
the chart-topper herself and it wasn't
long before people all over the world
became obsessed I think the reaction is
you know pretty much what I expected in
American society we read a lot of sexual
fantasies but they're always from the
male point of view and I don't think
there's a lot of women there coming out
and you know sort of giving the female
point of view the aluminum book cover in
case a hundred and twenty eight pages of
spiral-bound controversy and in between
the very suggestive photos
Madonna provided nuggets of wisdom such
as a lot of people are afraid to say
what they want that's why they don't get
what they want
unlike European cultures it's you know
sexist made into a dirty thing a taboo
subject ants and so of course people are
even more interested in knowing about it
and reading about it and that's really
one you know a point I made with with
the book to a certain extent the book
also featured cameos by supermodel Naomi
Campbell and Madonna's then-boyfriend
Vanilla Ice when I get through with it
she's very smart she's very aggressive
she's very tough-minded she knows
exactly what she wants she knows exactly
who her audiences and the message she's
giving to this audience is very clearly
one that she thinks they'll accept I
believe that my book was about
empowering women and celebrating women's
sexuality and telling women to be proud
of their bodies and their sexuality so I
believe that it was a very positive
thing as if all that wasn't enough media
hype the celeb packed launch party made
headlines all on its own yeah I mean you
know Madonna that's her job
the event was shrouded in secrecy and
even its high-profile guests didn't know
what to expect I don't know
I'm just going to a party what do you
think you're gonna see in there
hopefully some friends but coming out of
the party
he caught these reactions it was kind of
bizarre that was a peep show in the end
Madonna's out-of-the-box marketing
strategy paid off big-time sex sold over
a hundred and fifty thousand copies on
the day of its release
and sales of the book topped over five
hundred thousand by the following week I
think it's great I can't wait to get
home and look at it I expected that a
lot of people would be shocked and
everyone would say oh it's you know it's
trash but of course everyone went out
and bought it so I think that's pretty
much a reflection on our society isn't
it
the book was a publicity masterclass
that hasn't gone unnoticed by today's
biggest stars and it sent a message to
anyone who wants to grab the spotlight
like only Madonna can no risk no glory
[Music]